gewesen sagte daum und herren ist nicht
die gurke und das bloßstellen auch
wieder einfach giftig muss los bruder
meine sehr verehrten herz willkommen zu
einer neuen folge von essen testen heute
mit dabei eine runde applaus für den
mützen
ich habe wie immer leute fünf dinge
eingekauft wie du schon immer gehasst
hast da sind sachen die meine mutter bei
sowas
ich habe immer fünf dinge eingekauft die
du schon immer gehasst hass und der muss
eigentlich eigentlicher dabei die kommen
in jedem guten deutschen ukrainischen
rumänischen haushalt gerne mal vor
kündigt ist das was man essen kann noch
zu einem dauerbrenner aber ich bin heute
an deiner seite um dich durch dieses
tiefe tal der schmerzen zu bereiten ich
will sagen ich fange an mit der ersten
sache also mir das geleitet habe ich mir
schon gedacht und sollte das kuki nein
nein das für die menschen dass es ganz
ruhig mal sitzen lassen
jetzt fangen wir an mit der ersten sache
das ist wirklich etwas da habe ich mir
schon gedacht das grenzt schon an eine
verletzung der menschenwürde dass man so
was essen muss in diesem land du hast du
nämlich die grausame weise karotten
hatte alles das muss sagen leute riegler
ist aus ja also ich werde es kein gemüse
spanien betreiben aber so eine karotte
ist schon herbstlich schon mal keine
ahnung warum geht jemand herum sagten
lecker so dass noch nicht länger als man
die leute gehen so richtig dazu mit
karotten sind wir noch eine lücke
er weiß doch einfach mal hier oben ab
nee das war strengere kein bock ich
mache jetzt mittels das sieht schon aus
stufen zum teufel
ich weiß nicht immer den karten ist
sollte natürlich ist er besser kann auch
der kamera zu stehen
menschen nicht gesehen nicht abstoßen
okay die ja wir machen mit kurzen
prozess ja du hast dir wirklich
deren platzen ich kann auch nicht so
viel ich habe von einer woche bis jetzt
der kleine nicht ich habe jetzt weist
jetzt den forschungs deswegen so ganz
viel schwierig okay noch und kalt macht
ist echt hart also männer sind oft hart
aber dies anders hart von der bibel
mcqueen diese als normal aber so ganz
macht die sache erst dann gucken wir
andere youtuber sich überzeugen glaubt
man weiß nicht wie man da stattfinden
kann wie existieren pferde konnten die
nicht schon lange tot ist finnischen
regisseur platz ist oder doch sowieso
nach hause ist erst mal so ein kilo
geschmacksverstärker keine ahnung
schmeckt doch nicht geil gewesen
erzählen und auch immer noch dieser
staaten würde und dass das ein geiles
gilt nebenbei jetzt ja das ist auch
nicht so unbedingt es geht mehr darum
sich zu beschäftigen ja langweilig ist
dann deswegen wenn dies ist eine möhre
es ist wirklich seitdem ist ohne murren
haben bestimmt schon jahrzehnte
aber jetzt habe ich nichts geändert es
schmeckt für mich immer noch wie eine
dreckige erdige wiese wir haben doch
nicht geschält ja fucking ekelhaft aber
muss dann gucken nicht so
nicht so wenn ich gegen möhren hätte ja
reden möchte nehmen ihr studium habe ich
noch aufpassen
golf ist die hard knacken so schmecken
normal hören immer so sehe ich die
zerfällt er fordere
ja ich werde ja ich bin länger ich es
noch keine berichte
ich muss sagen diese hat wirklich eine
ganz besondere note dem abgang da ist so
eine so leichte ahnung von acker mit
dabei noch so ich muss eingestehen kann
man mit channel leute meistens beim
ersten artikel schon auch sehr gut darum
gedrückt haben sie zu schälen körper im
zweiten weltweite machen denn es
wirklich ganz normale dinge die in jedem
haushalt tausendfach vorrätig sind
du kannst du nicht so von da nach unten
holen jetzt muss von der seite kommt
du kannst nicht dass so nach oben
klappen würde einspannen richtig geile
mucke schneidet man die zeit macht gar
nicht wieder abgebissen
das bietet zusammengearbeitet und werden
wie mit den gurken war listen kann
okay okay das jetzt schon abschreiben
ich weiß finde ich vollkommen nach guter
alter haus uns hat einfach sein
jetzt ja jetzt vor wieder wie kriegen
werden möglichst dünn ist ein weiteres
großes ding ist es sich gruppen die
gurken jetzt einen lustvollen des von
mir an die gurke tours hat ein dünnes
filobok wie traurig ist einfach so einen
guten kern so rausgeschossen
plauen einfach nicht gemacht intensiv
schmeckt findest du schlimm dass weniger
nach diese oder der schmeckt halt die
abgestandenen wasser
ich möchte dass heute in wasserhaltiges
wasser lange stehen lässt so schmeckt
das also dann wäre kein haben das ist
für mich absolut genussmitteln also ich
muss sagen wirklich gucken sie einfach
geringer ist für mich tatsächlich so ein
ding klar gurken karotten das sind
beides nächste dinge die so
geschmacklich so rein fetzen wie so eine
geile pasta oder so aber das ist halt
gemüse das ist dafür da um es zu essen
wenn man langeweile hat das ist ja nicht
anders
es ist wirklich so wenn du alle träger
bislang ohne dass mit den fingern allen
digitalen ihr habt einfach mega lange
pacaya kartoffeln kartoffeln sagt er ja
stimmt ja ist so viele leute bei mir
drei von neun punkten ist noch am leben
jetzt ist doch bitte mal jedes ja ich
gebe ja nicht mal die möglichkeit
auszugehen dass aussuchen ob wir als
nächstes noch einmal gemüse wurde
wir haben nämlich noch aber gemüse oder
autoverkehr so in etwas mutigere oder
bayerischer richtig ist ich weiß das
nicht geschrieben haben dann sei alles
was jetzt kommt ist noch beschissener
als was bis dato aber lasst mich bitte
zu ende machen und dann reicht das koki
alles klar dann die nächste sache meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren du
kannst du wieder nicht der hut bringen
nicht nach einer großen stadt in der gut
kombiniert zunächst lade meine damen und
herren die sich die gurke und dass
dadurch die stelle auch wieder einfach
giftig dass ich dir so etwas antun
ich weiß dass sie daran
spätestens jetzt dem orient ist hier
kommt dass das schlimmste auf der welt
formaten das ist meine taktik ist dabei
einfach die tomaten oder abzuziehen und
dann so die tomaten kern heraus zu
schlürfen und was ich dann was hat das
recht nicht und es ist doch ehrensache
meisten hasse weil sie scheiße schmecken
bitter über die tomaten sind das
widerlichste global food der welt das
ist wie hören
ich muss aber dazu ist hören das ist
nicht geil
nichts davon ist geil oder lecker das
schmeckt so ekelhaft das schmeckt
einfach wie alt du kannst du noch ich
habe tatsächlich schon mal hin gegessen
ich kann bestätigen dass ich auch kein
höheres hast du essen ein
ich habe jetzt haben wir uns kein scheiß
was schon in schönried nein
genau deswegen warum findet man sowas
geil dass sie so den mund spritzt dieses
höheren masse zeug was los mit dir
[Musik]
gehört zu abhängigen kurzem wichtig kern
aus der tomate rauswürfen finde ich toll
[Musik]
man muss man das wirklich nur tomaten
leute sind rewe bio tomaten keine
scheiße eingeschleppt dank kann auch
nicht sagen wenn jemand nach fleisch hat
so ihr wissen kobr in manchen bisschen
so was macht ein bisschen besser und wir
haben genau dann kann ich ja der stände
sagen herzlichen glückwunsch die gemüse
klein sind vorbei
naja jetzt würde sie ja nur noch besser
jetzt zu verbessern die nächste seite
ist auch so also heute und zweifel ich
wirklich meinen grundsätzen meine sind
alles dinge die ich quasi jeden tag esse
und zwar einfach ein geiler deutscher
schnittkäse 48% im trocken heißt ja
perfekt dann nehmen und zu den menschen
hier raus aber der ist übrigens auch mit
musik aus wertvoller bergbauern okay
ganz kurz erstmal groß fest
riestern ist das ekelhaft geschmacklich
also schmecken einfach ich finde auch
dass es gut aussieht aber es schmeckt
einfach nicht da ist mir das problem
aber das okay alles klar kommst du jetzt
macht bitte nicht so ein scheiß du
kannst dich die person millimeter dinge
abschneiden mich wirklich gerecht mir
ist wirklich kotzübel einfach nur von
der traumatischen dann kannst du erstmal
somit bei mäßigem zuschauer ist das
jetzt die asset pool stück geben ich
finde das so wieder nicht dass das gut
an käse ist schmeckt nach fuß
aber hat die konsistenz von gummi
deutsche sturm kämpft mit dem überleben
ich habe mir gedacht was machen wir
jetzt wir müssen den retten und zwar mit
artikel nummer 5 der ist wirklich mit
lackierten youtube wächst und zwar magst
du das ja also ich würd ich geil dass
ich finds sich geheimnummer gegessen
deswegen kann ich das erst hab ich kenne
niemanden der so was ist das ist das für
mich ich habe aber auch noch nie
gegessen durch einen fleck
sagte heringsfilets in tomaten creme
einfach leiten die fressen alles okay
oder also wie man das macht ein bisschen
bessere oder ich habe es wirklich
provinz jetzt ist wieder die spannende
frage wie klein das stück für stück für
sich gut abschneidet 23 meist schon ewig
lang aufgenommen
du hast dich ist es aber zeitgleich mit
ihr hier das steht nicht so glücklich
aus ich mag die atmosphäre
das war so weit von diesem video leute
studiert und in der beschreibung
verlinkt er hat sich tapfer geschlagen
für uns hat sich seinen ängsten gestellt
schau dir das ist ein mann der sich sein
denkt denkt den karotten stellt sowie
darstellt ja ich hab mich darüber jetzt
auch ein kleines video verlinkt viele
zuschauer und bis zum nächsten mal macht